jacques chirac et en suède pour une
visite de deux jours il s'agit de
préparer les présidences successives de
l'union européenne le 1er juillet
prochain pour la france le 1er janvier
2001 pour la suède
le président français en a également
profité pour prendre position sur les
projets de rapprochement entre renault
et volvo dans le secteur des poids
lourds fait les boiseries la royauté n'a
pas été chiche avec la république même
si le roi carl xvi gustav aurait aimé en
faire plus mais jacques chirac a préféré
la limousine au carrosse pour cette
visite d'état où les voitures ont occupé
quelques conversations rumeurs de fusion
des fabricants de camions volvo et
renault oblige les yeux et ne croyez pas
qu'il y avait des différences
d'interprétation entre le premier
ministre suédois et jacques chirac juste
quelques problème d'oreillettes sur le
fond chacun a laissé la responsabilité
de ce mariage aux entreprises et à elle
seule
aujourd'hui ça de l'extérieur de
l'extérieur je pense qu'il est
souhaitable que des liens se créent
entre les grandes entreprises françaises
et les grandes entreprises sur et
jacques chirac d'en profiter pour saluer
le renforcement des liens économiques
entre la france et la suède depuis son
adhésion à l'union européenne en 95 et
comme le calendrier veut que les deux
pays se succèdent à sa présidence dans
les mois à venir
on a tenu à harmoniser les discours
pression fiscale entrée de la suède dans
l'euro ou élargissement de l'europe les
points délicats ne manquaient pas mais
la volonté de fusionner les drapeaux non
plus